on New Year's Eve Green Day do you
remember Green Day they were really
popular in 2002 and and we haven't heard
very much from them since but they're
back Green Day performed a version of
the only song of theirs that anyone has
ever heard of which is called American
Idiot but in in their new version they
swap out some words to make it an attack
on those magga
[Music]
[Applause]
Americans
I'm R part of the
[Music]
mag everybody
the you hear it they said magga agenda
and and I guess it works because people
are talking about Green Day for the
first time in over 20
years some people are surprised by this
change in part because punk rock has
sometimes had
a right-wing flavor to it wasn't one of
the Ramon a big right-wing Republican
and so there's been it's unlike all of
the rest of popular music outside of
country say it's not totally leftwing
but Green Day has always been super
left-wing there's no big change here
with with Green Day the original lyrics
to American Idiot in that line that that
you just heard where they changed some
of the words was quote well maybe I'm
the America I'm not part of a redneck
agenda now every do the propaganda and
sing along to the age of paranoia and
they just swapped out redneck for Maga
which every single lib in America
identifies as a synonym of redneck
anyway I don't want to be an American
Idiot One Nation controlled by the media
Information Age of Hysteria it's calling
out to idiot America okay so Green Day
hasn't changed they're still attacking
Republicans they're still attacking
right-wingers they're still attacking
the most recent republ
president but something has changed this
is much more ridiculous in 2023 than it
was in 2003 why is that well
because in 2002 2003 Green Day could be
could pretend to be part of the
opposition they could pretend to be
dissidents you know George W bush is out
here with his redneck Coalition of
Voters that's going to go out and police
the whole world and George Bush controls
the media that was always ridiculous
they say you know Fox News and and the
actually even the New York Times even
the rest of the media did support bush
in the Iraq War they didn't support Bush
most of the time but in the runup to the
Iraq War the entire media were were
pretty much on board with that so they
had a claim in 2002 2003 but what about
today does anybody really believes One
Nation controlled by the media refers to
the right-wing media are you kidding me
the right-wing media have been
banned there there's one social media
platform where the right-wing media are
not heavily suppressed and that would be
Twitter Information Age of hissteria
Information Age of where's the hysteria
is the hysteria on the right where we're
saying hey guys can maybe can you not
let husky Hank go into the girls
changing room at the public pool with my
daughter it would you mind can we can we
acknowledge that boys and girls are
different and Nations have borders and
can everyone be normal or is the
hysteria on the left where there're
screeching and screaming that Donald
Trump is Hitler 2.0 and that's why we've
got to kick him off all the ballots and
the only way to save democracy is to
stop the most popular candidate in the
race from from appearing on
ballots who's hysterical it's calling
out to idiot America idiot America okay
some
Americans don't know the difference
between boys and girls okay now I don't
like like to call anybody an idiot I
understand there's a lot of confusion in
this Fallen World but if you're going to
call someone an idiot if you're going to
call one ideology in America an idiot
ideology which ideology is it going to
be the ideology that says hey be normal
or the ideology that says Men actually
can be women Green Day hasn't changed at
all too bad that they haven't had they
changed they would appear much less
ridiculous today what has changed is the
political order of the country now I
haven't even touched on the biggest
controversy of this week off that we had
the it was all anyone could talk
about it is much more important than any
wars going on overseas much more
important than the migrant Invasion
going on within our borders much more
important than the 20124 election I of
course refer to the bikini
calendar if you have not heard about
this that means you were not on Twitter
during or X now between Christmas and
New
Year the calendar is put out by uh the
guy who has the ultra right beer company
Seth weathers and his brand is America
conservative dads and the the calendar
is conservative dads real women of
America 2024 calendar and it features a
bunch of pretty right-wing gals uh some
of whom perhaps have appeared on this
show and who I'm friends with actually
uh but you know a the one on the the
cover is Riley Gaines and a number of
other women are are in the calendar I
don't want to knock the calendar too
much because as I've mentioned I'm
friends with a number of the people
involved I think the big reason why this
became a controversy is because it was a
very quiet news week Christmas is going
on new year is going on people didn't
have that much to bicker about so uh
people bickered about this in part I
assume it was a marketing strategy to
sell more calendars and I assumed it
worked very well because everybody was
talking about it for a while the only
reason I bring up the
calendar the only thing about it that I
think is politically
significant is that I think the
controversy beyond all those other
causes I just mentioned stems from a
conflict a festering conflict that has
gone on for a very very long time but is
really coming to the surface now between
two kinds of
conservatism Boomer conservatism and
Zoomer
conservatism two kinds of conservatism
the conservatism of 15 years ago just
yeah man do whatever you want just don't
make me pay for it let's shrink the
government let's not pay any taxes
Freedom there's that kind of
conservatism and there's the younger
Zoomer conservatism which is hey can we
please have a normal society can we
maybe recall some of the virtues can we
have order can we have normality can
we can can we have a nice flourishing
country in which to live that has
standards and Norms those are very
different types of conservatism okay
I think you know where my sympathies lie
in this kind of battle but that's what
this battle is it really has nothing to
do it has very little to do with the
pretty ladies who are posing in the
calendar it has a little bit to do with
the fact that the brand happens to be
conservative dad so even if you're fine
with pretty girls in a calendar you know
the fact that it's being marketed by and
perhaps two fathers who should be
married with women who are married and
that kind of creates a little bit of an
issue with it
wouldn't wouldn't necessarily recommend
that but below all of that the deeper
issue going on is a battle between
Russell Kirk and Ein Rand who has the
soul of the conservative movement is
conservatism about conserving a way of
life and Order and norms and a a a moral
sense and maybe a a Christian religious
tradition or is conservatism just about
freedom do whatever you not even again
not my view of freedom but Freedom like
you know just go do whatever you want
don't tell me what to do man get out of
here Authority right what is it Russell
Kirk or Iran Rand is it Pat Buchanan or
is it George HW Bush that we had this
debate in 1992 what is it is it the
conservatism of normality a way of life
a whole political order or is it let's
get that GDP up
again is is it the conservatism of order
and virtue
is it the conservatism of choice and
Lous that's that's the battle and
probably the Calendar's Defenders would
say oh Michael you're making a big deal
out of it I'm not I'm not denying that
this issue was overblown it was
overblown because people were bored over
chismas no doubt but that political
conflict that the calendar represents
that is very real and that is not
overblown that's that's a conflict that
has been simmering in the so-called
conservative movement going back to
World War II okay going back to the
founding of what is called called
Capital C capital M conservative
movement trademark over the T that's
been boiling for a long time which is it
going to be Brent Bosell had this
argument in the pages of National Review
back when National Review was the house
organ of the conservative movement said
freedom of
virtue what does what does freedom even
mean right that's what's going on here
which side is winning well the dominant
side Remains the Boomer side because the
Boomers still wield most of the
political power but the ascendant side
is the Zoomer side the ascendant side is
order and virtue which is fine by me man
what a great clip that was now hold up
wait wait ring that Bell subscribe to
the Michael NS YouTube channel we'll see
you next time